hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
today a huge discovery was revealed in
the second official Avengers endgame
trailer but not the one that was
released on YouTube it's from the one
that was released on Instagram this
happened last year as well on Instagram
with an Avengers infinity war TV spot
the TV spot on Instagram actually
revealed to us that Thanos had the sole
stone in his Infinity Gauntlet before
going to Wakanda revealing that the sole
stone was actually not going to be the
last stone that Dan is collected this is
due to the aspect ratio of videos on
Instagram and thanks to that aspect
ratio a pretty big discovery has been
made before we dive into it a quick
reminder about my giveaway I'm giving
away five imax tickets so if you'd like
to enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so this involves
the scene where ant-man is out of the
quantum realm and he's looking at the
pole with all of the missing person
posters on it and again we can see a
little bit more in this scene thanks to
the aspect ratio of videos that are on
Instagram and in the scene if you look
in his right hand you can see that he's
holding something he's holding a handle
to something and it's most likely the
handle to Hank Pym 'he's laboratory when
it's shrunk this just makes perfect
sense because when he gets out of the
quantum realm finally he won't be able
to find Hank Janet or Hope because they
were victims to the snap but he'll
definitely go search for them and when
he does it seems like he's going to take
their lab with him which again makes
perfect sense because when Scott gets
out of the quantum realm he's going to
go into a world that is completely
different and once he finally realizes
what has happened he'll most likely go
and get the lab for safekeeping and from
there he'll head to the Avengers
headquarters and this is most likely how
Tony is going to be able to build these
new quantum realm suits all of Hank Pym
technology will be inside of the lab
he'll have access to all of it and Hank
Pym zweite quantum realm suit will most
likely be in there as well which we know
thanks to marvel calm the white suits
that the Avengers are going to wear are
modeled after the one that Hank Pym
wears this also means that there are
most likely two ways to enter the
quantum realm one is the small quantum
tunnel in the back of Louis's van and
the other would be the main quantum
tunnel in the laboratory this may not
matter too much if both quant
tunnels put you in the same place in the
quantum realm but if they send you in
two different places inside of the
quantum realm in theory the Avengers
could split up and do separate missions
travelling back to different points in
time at the same time but whatever it
may be it does seem like thanks to this
trailer on Instagram
Scott will find Hank PIMs laboratory
shrink it down carry it with them to the
Avengers headquarters
give it to Tony Stark and from there he
will figure out the science and
technology needed to travel inside of
the quantum realm and make the Avengers
their white suits this would definitely
explain how Tony Stark gets the
technology and the knowledge about the
quantum realm to make these suits and
perhaps with the help of Hank Pym slab
Tony Stark figures out how to control
the time vortices inside of the quantum
realm so let me know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below it seems
pretty obvious that ant-man would be
carrying Hank Pym slab and of course we
know from other trailers he ends up at
the avengers headquarters but let me
know if you think that is something else
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on everything relating
to Avengers endgame and all things
Marvel as always thank you all so much
for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]